one of the things i want to spend a lot
of time talking about
is this idea of maximalism uh and
you know before we we recorded this i uh
tweeted out and said hey i'm having eric
on the podcast
uh what questions do you have for him
and there's all kinds of crazy stuff
there's some that were really thoughtful
intelligent
uh questions and then there was things
that basically
you know kind of try to paint you to be
an enemy of bitcoin i guess maybe let's
just start with like
what are your thoughts about bitcoin and
that ecosystem and then what are your
thoughts about
everything that's not bitcoin you know
do you support kind of both
and then how do you think about uh
almost participating in both ecosystems
at the same time
yeah good question it's good to start
with first principles like that
so i have been involved in bitcoin since
2011.
it is you know like my first life's
passion
it has been my career it has been my
hobby it has been my passion for a
decade
and when i found bitcoin i saw in it
a solution to what i thought was the
biggest problem in the world which is
government's control over money
so everything i do since then has been
to help bring bitcoin to the world now
bitcoin is a complicated
technology and society is a complicated
thing to bring that technology to
um and as bitcoin has grown i've seen
the value
in other systems that are built on
blockchains also
being in partnership with bitcoin so i
see it as one ecosystem
right i see the decentralization that
bitcoin promised
best expressed when there are other
blockchains and there are other systems
i do not think
a monolithic chain that handles
everything for everyone and solves all
problems is decentralization i think
that's a that's
that would be a weaker more brittle
structure part of the
dynamism and part of the strength and
resiliency
of a decentralized financial world is
one built on multiple blockchains that
optimize for different things
bitcoin has taken a very conservative
approach to optimizing to be the best
form of money ever made by mankind
i think it has done better at that than
any other project
easily most of my net worth is and
always has been in bitcoin and will
continue to be
and yet i see ethereum as an extremely
valuable ecosystem
i see zcash and monero and haven and
privacy coins as extremely important
tools
for financial privacy i see this stuff
getting built in defy
and how how much destruction that will
rain down on the entire banking system
and all i can do is applaud that and so
when people get mad at me because i'm
not only bitcoin
uh it it saddens me it's like you know
what what are you
what are you actually here for are you
here for orange coin
or are you here to actually bring
decentralized finance and a new
form of money to the entire world
because the other communities that are
building around bitcoin
are have that same mission and they
should be seen as allies instead of
enemies
this is really interesting because i
think that um
ever since i met you right uh it's never
uh been at question right i think your
commitment to bitcoin
and and wanting to see it be successful
i think throughout history
of bitcoin uh there's been all sorts of
debates and opportunities and
and uh various points in time where uh
people
did debate you know what's the best way
to bring it forward but i always try to
remind people that
uh you know everyone is trying to
accomplish the same goal
the path to get there is where the
debates occur but i don't think that
anyone
uh who has spent as much time as you
have or others
uh in bitcoin want to see it fail right
or or for some reason
uh don't believe in it etc right kind of
ridiculous
it's such an absurd notion um and it
worries me because bitcoin does have
some very serious enemies
and we have only started to awaken those
enemies
and so if the bitcoin community and if
the larger crypto community itself
is infighting all the time and just
tearing each other down
they are going to be missing the actual
enemy
which is the state which is the banking
system that is what this stuff is
in opposition to bitcoin is not in
opposition to ethereum
it is no coincidence that the two
systems have grown up together and are
hitting all-time highs together
they are collaborative they are
community together and
that stands in stark contrast to fiat
currency to the banking system
and to states which try to control money
from the from the center
so i i want people to orient their
vision outside of those proper
enemies because there are many of them
yeah and when you think about
uh the technology it seems like uh
there's a thought process of almost uh
on a kind of horizontal standpoint all
of the technology that is going after
true decentralization and is trying to
bring
uh some sort of uh value or
functionality
uh to this decentralized digital
ecosystem uh via
decentralized open protocols you're a
fan of right you're saying hey
this is all good it's all moving us in
the uh right direction
but then there's this like social layer
right
and the social layer is everything that
doesn't involve the technology and this
is where you get the max
maximalism the tribalism uh the the
marketing messages
the infighting all that kind of stuff
and so
is that stuff healthy is it agnostic
like does it actually not matter at all
it's just whatever the technology that
works ends up being the most important
thing and and
everything else just a distraction like
how do you think about the social layer
maybe different than the technology
layer
yeah and the social layer is really like
the most important one which most people
don't recognize this this is technology
meant to be used by humans
and lives to serve humans um
i think it's important and and what a
lot of the maximalists do
correctly is to have a very high degree
of skepticism
toward any project right whether it's a
bitcoin company
or whether it's some new chain or coin
there's a lot of crap out there there's
a lot of garbage
there are a lot a lot of scams
absolutely
so i would never want people to just
like blanketly accept anything in the in
the ecosystem because it's crypto
most of the stuff is garbage and yet
there is a core
of projects which are legitimate run by
very smart people that
that share these ideologies and which
are building
world-changing technology and so to just
be open-minded to the things which have
quality uh i think is important and if
everything is called a scam
you get a phenomenon just like how the
you know how the government says like
you should never do drugs right just say
no
and you get this whole generation rising
up and realizing that oh if they smoke a
joint with a friend
and they didn't die maybe the government
is actually wrong about other things
uh it's like don't lose your credibility
by calling every project in crypto other
than your favorite coin is scam it does
not help anyone and i think it only
it only perpetuates like uh an
atmosphere of animosity and doesn't
actually get to the truth of what these
projects are